il nous a rejoints il faisait partie de
la toute première bande de tpm pays même
la toute première émission sur france 4
c'est le 1er avril 2010
c'est mon thierry moreau comment ça va
motiver ça va très bien a renchéri ce
mois ci dont elle n'a pas changé il ya
bien eu un clou quelques années mais
vous n'avez pas de changer en tout cas
aborder toujours on est toujours aussi
ont ils fait gilles est toujours aussi
floue bon thierry d'amour est ce que tu
te rappelles de ta première parce que
j'étais première live pour oui je me
rappelle de ma première parce qu'en fait
j'avais avaient été tués dans une
émission qui s'appelait pif paf à
l'époque était diffusée sur paris
première
je vais contacter pour un casting quand
je dis aux gens de paris première que
j'allais faire ce casting m'ont dit mais
qu'est ce que tu vas faire avec ceux se
fout de syrie la tna moi je te connais
pas les portes je suis parti pour fair
touche pas à mon poste j'ai quitté qui
monte à se prêter sur une équipe dans un
stade où je partais sur un truc qui
marcherait jamais ça et puis j'ai arrêté
deux mois après et ben et voilà et on
fête les 10 ans aujourd'hui mon thierry
je suis très heureux que tu sois avec
nous pour les disant je vais te montrer
ta première télé et me thierry est ce
que pour ce soir est ce que pour les
hôpitaux parce que ça vaut 100 balles
est ce que tu peux nous faire une petite
blague de thierry moreau juste après
parce que les blagues de thierry moreau
c'est devenu culte dans mlp regarde et
iris tête à première télé sur france 4
milliards d'actions
thierry mottier
[Applaudissements]
un plaisir vous êtes le plus chic de
l'émission euros oui je me suis dit
qu'il y mettre une cravate je me
démarque comme un petit peu tout le
monde vous vous démarquez je vous le
confirme
est ce que vous êtes le seul ami de
benji ou est-ce que c'était trop bien
payés et que les infos arrivent et je
les fais surtout par plaisir pour
pouvoir avoir cette cette co animation
et cette partie de rigolade avec
l'impasse qui m'amuse beaucoup et puis
franchement mais je n'ai pas fait pour
l'argent
même si c'est toujours important très
bien bas applaudissements pour tirer et
je m'en rappelle il y avait une rubrique
tu faisais une interview thierry ça
s'appelle comment déjà
mais l'interview méchante où j'ai pu
commencer c'est toi qui avais trouvé de
nom mais comment s'appelait c'est avec
ces puces tech moreau il y avait moreau
dans le titre et thierry moreau ça me
fait plaisir de le voir saint-christophe
ça fait plaisir de voir thierry parce
que n'arrive souvent brouillée qu'il est
dehors dans les bistrots mais on s'aime
beaucoup thierry on s'est beaucoup ainsi
comme j c'est pareil pour toi c'est
pareil pour toi on tire est ce que tu
peux nous faire une petite blague
bah oui c'est une blague pourrie un bien
évidemment ça se passe dans un bar oui
aia et un policier qui rentre dans le
bureau du commissaire et qui dit chef
chef il ya un braquage aurait supérette
on a volé 5 kg de carottes et des
cartouches de cigarettes et le
commissaire répond et vous avez un
suspect et oui on recherche un lapin qui
tousse amérique je te fais de gros
bisous moity réelle bonne route est ce
que tu fais sur lci bravo mon chéri